the diagram below contains parallelogram
abcd so that's parallelogram abcd and
triangle efg and they tell us which of
the angles have a measure of 90 degrees
and they label it here as well and they
tell us which of the angles have a
measure of 31 degrees and they label it
here as well
which of the qualities must be true i
encourage you to now pause this video
and try to figure this out on your own
so now let's look at this first
statement tangent of angle adc so let's
think about the tangent
of angle a
d
c
so this is angle adc right here a dc
to remind ourselves the definition of
tangent will break out sohcahtoa
sine is opposite over hypotenuse
cosine so
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse toa
tangent is opposite over adjacent
so what is the opposite side to this
angle so we're dealing with this right
triangle triangle adc let me highlight
it so that we know we're dealing with
this right triangle right over here
that's the only right triangle that
angle adc is part of and so what side is
opposite
is opposite angle adc
well it's side
it's side ca or i guess i say ac
side ac so that is opposite
and what side is adjacent what side is
adjacent well this side dcd
cd or i guess i could call it dc
whatever i want to call it
dc or cd is adjacent
now how did i know that this side is
adjacent and not side d a because d a is
the hypotenuse they both together make
up the two sides of this angle but the
adjacent side is the side that makes up
is one of the sides of the angle that is
not the hypotenuse a d or d a in the
sohcahtoa context we would consider to
be the hypotenuse for this angle this is
opposite this is adjacent this is
hypotenuse tangent of this angle is
opposite over adjacent ac over dc ac
over dc now is that what they wrote here
no they wrote ac over ef
well where's ef ef is nowhere to be seen
either in this triangle or even in this
figure this ef is this thing right over
here
ef
ef is this business right over here
that's ef it's in a completely different
triangle in a completely different
figure we don't even know what scale
this is drawn at there's no way the
tangent of this angle is related to this
somewhat arbitrary number that's over
here they haven't labeled it this thing
might be a million miles long for all we
know it could be this thing really could
be any any number so this isn't this
isn't the case we would have to relate
it we would have to relate it to
something within this triangle or
something that's the same length so
somehow we could prove that ef is the
same length as dc then we could go with
that but there's no way this this is a
completely different figure a completely
different diagram this is a similar
triangle to this but we don't know
anything about the lengths the similar
triangle just lets us know that the
angles are all the same or that the
ratio between corresponding sides might
be the same but it doesn't tell us what
this number right over here doesn't tell
us that this side is somehow congruent
to dc so we can't go with this one
now let's think about the sign of cba
so the sign let me do this in a
different color so the sine of angle cba
sine of angle c
b a
so that's this angle right over here c b
a
well sine is opposite over hypotenuse
the opposite side
the opposite side if we look at i guess
let me make it clear which triangle
working i'll do this in yellow we're now
looking at this triangle
right over here
the opposite side
the opposite side is a c
that's what the angle opens up into
so it's going to be equal to a c
and what is the hypotenuse what is the
hypotenuse here well the hypotenuse so
let me see it's opposite over hypotenuse
the hypotenuse is bc the hypotenuse is
bc right over here it's a side opposite
the 90 degree side
so this
it's bc
sine is opposite
opposite
over
opposite over hypotenuse so over
bc
is that what they drew over or what they
wrote over here no they have dc over bc
now what is dc equal to
well dc is this and dc
is not there's no there's no evidence on
this drawing right over here that dc is
somehow equivalent to
ac so given this information right over
here we can't make this statement either
so neither of these neither of these are
true and so let's let's make sure we got
this right we can go back to our actual
exercise
and we get
we get oh that's not the actual exercise
let me minimize
let me
minimize that this is neither of these
are true and we got it right